let's bring in now Sami Abu shaheda he's
the head of the balad party and a former
member of the Israeli knesset he joins
us now from hia thanks very much for
being with us Sammy when you hear voices
like imams coming from Gaza what they
are having to endure there as this form
of collective punishment what is your
response to
that Laura first of all thank you for
bringing these voices from this uh
unbelievable uh situation first of all
I'm from yafa hundreds of thousands of
the people who are living in in Gaza are
in the origins from yafa Israel is bom
we we are now able to to to to hear the
voices on the story of of Iman and her
children till the next Israeli pilot of
the Air Force will choose them as as one
of his targets What's Happening Here is
unbelievable Joe Biden the American
president has given Israel that did not
need need too much encouragement a green
light for ethnic cleansing this is
exactly what's happening you are having
one of the biggest and strongest Air
Forces in the whole world bombing such a
very small City where two and two
2,200,000 people are living all of them
are chosen as targets and the Israeli
Prime Minister and the Israeli defense
minister yesterday they called them in
their press conference animals and
imagine now in 2023 prime minister
defense minister is describing 2,200,000
people as animals all the world is
knowing that Israel is planning and they
don't have any rational thinking or any
anything to say to the world they are
saying that they want to get revenge
they are led by this mentality of
Destruction and revenge they have all
the power to do so and they have been
doing the
then like this for the last four four
days I just want to jump in there Sam
because I want to pick up on one point
what you say is absolutely true that
we're getting blanket immunity from the
US from the West towards Israel but you
do say that they give Israel the green
light to act like this some might also
say that Hamas and its unprovoked well
it's not unprovoked on its attack it's
unprecedented attack on Israel also gave
Netanyahu the excuse to respond in this
manner on
Gaza let me be clear about this story
first of all we are against hurting not
killing hurting any innocent people
anywhere in the world okay I want to be
clear about this but in the same time
not not the 2,200,000 people are not
leadership of of Hamas in G and Israel
is not killing the leadership of Hamas
they are not getting revenge out of
Hamas they is collective punishment to
2,200,000 not just in Gaza look what's
happening towards the Palestinians in
the West Bank look what's happening
towards the Palestinians to us the
Palestinian Israelis that we live as
Israeli citizens inside the state of
Israel our lives are under danger
because of all the extreme right-wing
fascists that want to get revenge also
from the population from civilians we
did not do anything because we are
Palestinians we are a Target now for
this mob of fascists all over what's
happening now is giving a green light to
another ethnic cleansing for the
Palestinian people this must stop Laura
what we are asking for is stopping the
Bloodshed we just want this war to stop
we want to see an end we want to see a
ceasefire and then to bring rational
political way of thinking we will not go
out of this trap of violence that we
want to to end this any vicious circle
of violence but the only way to do that
is through rational peaceful way of
thinking sitting on the table and
getting to a just solution for the
Palestinian issue okay you you're a
former member of the Israeli knesset how
much rational thinking is happening
there now do you think because we've got
Netanyahu calling for a United wartime
cabinet calling in members of the
opposition but the opposition laying
down it seems in public at least some
preconditions that me far-right members
of his current Coalition are not part of
that
cabinet Laura the political situation
Israel is really shocking all of the
parties are agreeing on the destruction
and ethnic cleansing there is no
opposition for the war imagine a whole
society wants to see massacres want to
they are calling for war crimes
opposition and Coalition are calling for
war crimes I'm really shocked it's
unbelievable that a whole soci Society
in order they are LED totally by this
mentality of Jewish superiority and this
mentality of phist way and of
dehumanizing the Palestinians all the
Palestinians all over what do you mean
you want to kill all the Palestinian
what is this kind of say why is this
legitimate for any politician in the
world to talk in this way towards any
other people also if there has been
mistakes or anything wrong the only way
to do it is through rational discourse
rational way of thinking not to lose any
all these things to this crazy
destructive Instinct of Revenge and this
district and this is very destructive it
will first of all we had in the last few
years six Wars on Gaza we heard all
these sentences of destroying Hamas
destroying Gaza this did not lead to
anywhere which is good for anyone okay
we want to and think in a rational way
that would lead us to a normal situation
to do peace and to bring historical
compromise between the two Sid the only
way to do that is through and last
sentence please La the only way to do
that is through leading a political
solution which is based on Justice and
equality for all Palestinians and
Israelis we want to see an end of this
Bloodshed we want to see an end of this
conflict okay yes we here we hear and
understand you want to see if cool heads
prevail Sami Abu shaheda Thank you very
much for joining us here on Al jazer